[Musique]
les végétaux on va les prendre les
bananes vous avez droit par exemple
[Musique]
la viande que vous allez retrouver ici
ça va être de la viande qui va être
destiné dans un premier temps à des
passagers qui le ramènent de leur pays
d'importation pour pouvoir le consommer
sur le territoire français complètement
ça va être soit pour les proches soit
pour la famille ou pour leur propre
consommation on va voir également un
autre typologie de fraude c'est-à-dire
des personnes qui vont apporter ce type
de marchandises pour pouvoir le revendre
sur le territoire national sur un marché
noir ou sur le sur l'Union européenne
[Musique]
on est face à un crime organisé un crime
international avec des incidences pour
les populations locales et puis des
risques ici pour les populations qui
peuvent consommer ou être en contact
avec ces espèces et enfin c'est un une
des raisons principales de disparition
de la biodiversité
[Musique]
on sait et on a analysé depuis plusieurs
années que si on réduit les bagages on
réduit cette importation il faut
évidemment pouvoir aussi changer la
règlementation internationale et les
obligations du transporteur côté
passager il faut accompagner ça par des
campagnes sur les risques encourus
sanitaires et les risques pénaux
[Musique]